donald trump l'affirmé en février
dernier le coronavirus n'est pas pire
que la grippe
il disparaîtra avec la hausse des
températures au printemps huit mois plus
tard c'est un sérieux coup du destin
pour le locataire de la maison blanche
ce soir la première dame et moi avons
été testé positif aux convives 19
nous commençons immédiatement notre
processus de quarantaine et de
récupération
nous traverserons cette épreuve ensemble
donald trump et les risques liés aux
kobe 19 c'est une histoire compliquée
dès l'apparition du virus le président
américain avait clairement annoncé qu'il
ne porterait pas de masque dénonçant un
comportement alarmiste de la part des
instances médicales et de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
pourtant avec un poids officiel de 110
kg une tension artérielle à surveiller
et un faible revendiquer pour la
nourriture grasse le président de 74 ans
ferait partie des gens les plus à risque
selon de nombreux médecins
il a fallu attendre mi juillet pour que
donald trump change d'avis notamment sur
le port du masque un virage à 180° en 24
heures je veux que les gens est une
certaine liberté et je ne suis pas
d'accord avec l'affirmation selon
laquelle si tout le mot met un masque
qui tout va disparaître
nous sommes unis dans nos efforts pour
vaincre cet invisible virus chinois
beaucoup de gens disent que c'est un
acte patriotique de porter un masque
quand la distance physique ne peut être
maintenue il n'y a pas plus patriotes
que moi votre président préféré la
contamination au kobe 19 tombe très mal
pour le président américain candidat à
sa réélection
il doit aujourd'hui annuler tous ses
meetings une mauvaise nouvelle pour ses
partisans qu'ils s'apprêtaient à
l'applaudir en floride ce samedi dans le
wisconsin dimanche en géorgie lundi et
en arizona mardi et mercredi
il aurait pu être contaminé par une de
ses plus proches collaboratrices propres
x testée positive un peu plus tôt et qui
avait accompagné donald trump à
cleveland pour le débat télévisé contre
joe biden un débat pendant lequel donald
trump s'était moqué de son adversaire
démocrate pour avoir fréquemment porter
un masque depuis le début de sa campagne
si l'état du président était amené à se
dégrader
c'est le vice président mike pence qui
assurait alors l'intérim
une situation qui s'est déjà produite
aux etats unis pendant quelques heures
sous ronald reagan et sous george bush
junior